are people really interested in having
in car advertising absolutely they're
interested in the same way their
interest in any advertising which is it
reduces cost of products so the reason
we have free television is not because
television networks are nice guys want
to give it away for free they do it
because they were advertising subsidize
the whole most of the print industry is
advertising subsidized so the idea is
that if we could subsidize other
features for you by giving you
advertising you'd like it so I take I
get air conditioning as long as I had a
bundle
we're here with Clifford Nass who's
director of chai with John China is the
communication between humans and
interactive media lab here at Stanford
University and Goodwin I didn't want to
say I know boy so what's the point of
chime where did you come up with the
idea and this is really your baby so you
can just kind of give us a broad a broad
overview of China sure so about 15 or 20
years ago I got interested in the idea
that people treat technologies not as
tools but as people so we wanted to see
if people would be polite to computers
so add them work with the computer and
in one case the computer they work with
there's questions how well did it do how
smart was this computer etc for the
other half of people we put them in
another computer across the room and no
one said however that computer do how
smart was it etc and people were nicer
to the computer that asked about itself
now who were these people were these
sort of you know idiots or something
like that no they turned out to be
graduate students in computer science at
Stanford when we come upon these weird
20th and 21st century devices that
interact and speak and use words are
being immediately kicks in aha I must
treat it like a person who knows my busy
the matter it was probably just a bad
professor Nass here we are I'm sitting
in the simulator how are these
simulations different from a video game
so first of all they're not meant to be
a game they're meant as much as possible
reflect actual driving we don't have
cars going 150 miles an hour 250 miles
an hour we don't have people with the
goal of hitting people although we do
see some of that here so that's one big
difference the other big differences
we're gathering an enormous amount of
data about the driver we can track
almost everything about what you're
doing we also do physiology we can hook
you up with sensors on your skin on your
heart on your brain to detect what
that's doing so we're working a lot with
car companies to take the things we
discover and apply them to actual
products so one thing we discovered for
example was that if you're happy you
should have you do better with a happy
voice hi my name is chris and i will be
your virtual passenger for today by
doing better it means you drive better
have less accidents you you enjoy it
more you listen to a more you believe it
more etc but
unhappy drivers actually do better with
a flat subdued voice that most people in
the here go oh my god that person sounds
almost oppressed hi my name is chris and
i'll be your virtual passenger for today
but in fact when your misery loves not
company the old say misery loves company
misery loves miserable company that's
really what's going on they are so in
fact people do better with that if the
car if voice one in the car is the one
that's saying you know turn left turn
right you miss this that are your
engines low we might want a nicer voice
to tell you the good things that are
happening like or advertised to you so
there's a lot of work on getting cars to
advertise and wouldn't it be great if it
was a much more compelling friendly
voice that said to you hey you know why
don't you eat at Joe's it's lunchtime
and why don't we go to Joe's as opposed
to the same voice going your engine
fluid is low you're you know in bad
shape and so all these things could
happen is cars get more intelligent they
can become more helpful to you it's kind
of moving some of these ideas of
contextual advertising off of the
desktop and off of the phone until your
car which is moving through these areas
face exactly in context and mobility is
exactly where its most powerful the
reason that target advertising hasn't
been as effective on the pc is because
most of the advertising i want is what
i'm doing at that moment if i'm out and
about i mean a moving thing so i have
Billy to move and somewhere at a given
time etc now all of a sudden that's
where the real payoffs and contextual
advertising will come so why wouldn't I
just use my iphone for that purpose like
why why put it into another car why
bring like another gadget you know
what's a great question that's one of
the business model questions here who's
going to make money off this is that the
car companies is it the telecoms is it
the apples of the world so that's one
question the other question is will the
car companies allow the ipod or iphone
to tap into the car itself because the
car has lots of information about you
like you're driving really fast it's
unlikely you're going to want to turn
off at the next exit if you're going
super fast so there's things the cart
can know also the iphone right now can
track where you're going right but
whereas with a car's GPS that's running
twenty-four seven so it could notice you
stop every day at six o'clock in a
restaurant
so it knows that boy if it's 620 this
guy is going to be really hungry this
could have an enormous impact on the
success of my advertising as cars gather
more data about you and get smarter
about you who gets to own it who gets to
control it this is exactly at the core
of what society is going to have to
confront not just our society but
societies throughout the world as we got
the more data and cause you're an
amazing position to gather data not just
where you are when you're doing it how
stressed you want because cars now we'll
have video cars now we'll have audio so
we can analyze that decide how angry
were you so your car will know whether
you're angry now we could use that in a
positive way reduce frustration make you
happier we could use that in the
negative way report to the police this
guy's pretty angry you better watch him
I don't trust him on the road right now
because he's a bad guy so all of these
technologies have potential to be
tremendously helpful or tremendously
destructive
you